تصريحاتهم واتصالات متعاقبه تلتزم بالسوء
مسالا سياسيا يكثر حده تصعيد بين روسيا
والغرب على خلفيه الحرب في اوكرانيا ورغم
ذلك تبدو هو في مواقف الطرفين على حالها
الغرب يسر على انسحاب روسيا من اوكرانيا
كان نقطه بدايه لاي حل دبلوماسي وهو ماكده
المستشار الالماني للرئيس الروسي اليوم
وفي المقابل لا يجدد الكريم لا تاكده على
الانفتاح على الحوار لكن ذلك
رهن بقبول الغرب مطالب موسكو والتي من
اجلها بدات الحرب
وقال الكريم ان محاولات تفاوض معه
واشنطلون
في اوروبا قبل بدء الحرب باءت بالفشل
واضاف الكريم ان البيض يشترط انسحاب روسيا
من اوكرانيا وهو معتبره غير ممكن مؤكدا ان
العمليه العسكريه متواصله
وقال المتحدث
انه واشنطن لا تزال ترفض الاعتراف
بالاراضي الجديده لروسيا وان هذا يعقد
البحث عن ارضيه المشتركه للنقاش حسب
تعبيره وشدد على ان افضل طريقه لتسويه
الوضع في اوكرانيا هي دبلوماسيح
وكان رئيس الامريكي قد اكد استعداده
للحديث مع رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اذا
اظهر الزعيم الروسي
نيه لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا وقال ان
الطريقه الوحيده لانهاء الحرب هي انسحاب
روسيا من اوكرانيا لكن ايضا اضاف ان بوتين
لن يفعل ذلك
رقم واحد يبدو انه لن يفعل ذلك انه يدفع
ثمن باهظا لفشله في القيام بذلك لكنه
لا تصدق للسكان المدنيين في اوكرانيا
حضور رعايه الاطفال ما يفعله شيئا مقزز
لكن في الواقع ليس لدي اي قطط ملحه
في كلامي انا مستعد للحديث الى بوتين اذا
كانت هناك في الواقع مصلحه في ان يبحث عن
وسيله لانهاء الحرب لم يفعل ذلك حتى الان